DOROTHY: You suppose there is such a place, Toto?
DOROTHY: There must be.
DOROTHY: It's not a place you can get to by a boat
- or a train...
It's far, far away...
Behind the moon
Beyond the rain
*Inspirational, Upbeat Electronic Music*
HAGRID: Yer a wizard, Harry.
SAMWELL: If I take one more step...
It'll be the farthest away from home I've ever been.
*Ambient, Electronic Cover of "Somewhere Over The Rainbow"*
YODA: Do, or do not.
There is no try.
DAVE: Open the pod bay doors, HAL.
HAL: *emotionless, robotic voice*
I'm sorry, Dave.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
CHUCK: WILSON!
CHUCK: *desperately* WILSON! WILSOOON!!!
*Electronic, Ambient "Somewhere Over the Rainbow" begins to fade*
NORM: I luv ya, Margie.
MARGIE: I love YOU, Norm.
SCARECROW: Won't you take me with you?
DOROTHY: Why, of course I will!
SCARECROW: Hooray! We're off to see a wizard!
DOROTHY: Oh, well, oh! Well you're not starting off very well!
SCARECROW: Oh, I'll try!
SCARECROW: Really I will!
DOROTHY: To Oz?
SCARECROW: To Oz!